hey new setup continues very epic isn't
that right that girl
say it today we're checking out 15 men
compete for five women that says a lot
about society and you goddamn know it
you got damn know it there's something
about guys competing for women that it's
just absolute cringe what's up gamers
today I have a very very very very
special announcement are you ready for
this it's something we've been working
on for quite a while
it's the arcade blast for baby what this
arcade blaster basically it's a
controller for your phone and it turns
you just attach it like that turn it on
and it connects instantly basically and
you're ready to game it takes mobile
gaming to the next level something
that's never been done before because
basically where you aim like this you'll
aim in the game who would have thought
mobile gaming was immersive it makes you
a better player it gives you an
advantage but it's also just a really
fun and unique way of playing I really
didn't have a blast when I played this
there's a ton of games for it modern
combat 5 was really fun
all right we're playing modern combat
fight look at this so cool just looking
around but the best part about this is
shooting bad guys oh I can scrape away
so easy moving sideways with your thumb
we look easy look around easy
helping bold guys easy don't call
yourself a gamer unless you have an
arcade blaster what's that
you play mobile games that's cringe bro
what's that you have an arcade blaster
you're in okay we're cool we're cool
okay we're cool shadow gun was really
fun I'm playing shadow gun war games
this time we're playing online as you
can see clearly she thinks too many
buttons
everyone knows more buttons better gamer
all right my first time playing Dan this
is so cool
I love just looking around Mike you
don't think so
look at my precision look at knees look
at that aim bro
ah behind me mobile gaming actually fun
what I even had fun playing fortnight
with it
now obviously the blaster has a ton of
games so it has to have fortnight I know
the kids like it I mean this is kind of
cool even fortnight it's cool with the
arcade blaster I'll say it I didn't
think I would say it oh you're welcome
fortnight I played two hours with ninja
no kills first time I have Bethel
glanced hi epic oh sorry I can't say
that but this will basically turn you
into a pro if you're doing mobile gaming
these buttons are super nifty and they
make you strafe left and right so you
can just use your thumb for easy
maneuver while you're aiming it vibrates
when you shoot so it feels immersive and
and fun it has a ton of buttons I think
it's safe to say there's no shortage of
them you even have a joystick as well
for extra precision and you can adjust
it as much as you like Android iPhone it
fits at all it's such a fun product I'm
really happy I'm working with our kid
with it's been really cool to see this
come to life so if you want one of these
please support it on IndieGoGo the
campaign is live now check it out
order yours now and I'll see you gamers
in-game with the arcade blaster don't
call yourself a gamer unless you have
one of these thanks for supporting the
project link in the description let's
get on with the video oh my god I forgot
to mention it also works with PC games
you can play with doom eternal how cool
is that
sorry let's say check it out when guys
do like a quick ways to hit on a woman
what do you do you do pickup line I'm
gonna say this honestly complete
honestly never done a pick-up line I
don't need to do pickup line
ok and neither should you I never
understand the women like pickup lines
they like it you like this I don't
understand this became a write about a
pickup lines I just find it so cringy a
girl should like boy for who he is not
what he say
something to think about anyway 15 men
compete for five women let's freakin do
this prepare for some cringe I actually
used to live out of us oh wow it's
already going you know a woman is
interested if she's making that face
definitely that guy is gonna win for
sure if you ever see a woman is that's a
sign of submission of a woman she wants
you just go for it rather than just
adhering to the social structures
enemies of society oh okay the average
dating app has three times more than men
than women what that is so unfair
everyone talked about different gap
there's different gap that no one talked
about dating gap let's imagine my head
nice well done Jubilee I see what you're
doing here alright so we have two
cameras set up we should place one in
front of them and the other one where
should we place the other one in front
of the women well play camera guy like
there's no need for that him with a fish
what the frickin is wrong what's wrong
with the guy in a fish look at them they
think it's hilarious
oh my god they they're acting like
that's the funniest thing they've ever
seen yeah because they're just
compensating this is a small peepee joke
and you know it you know it really you
think that's funny okay I don't see you
pose him
I mean it's parents you know this is
what guys are competing for it this is
what they don't know this this is this
[Music]
hey I already know this guy and this guy
are gonna win for no reason at all
alright so we have two other two out of
five the winners hi I'm amber I'm 22
years old
I collect pressed pennies 51 cents is
the way to my heart that's sweet I'm
Mackenzie I'm 21 years old and a million
people have seen me make out with a boy
online what alright I guess that's
another video I'm a full time
destination wedding photographer and I'm
a yoga instructor next one
boring country Pennsylvania literally
Mennonite and Amish children at my house
hi my name is Victoria I'm 26 years old
I'm a social-media influencer no next
I don't like social media influencers my
name is Jackie I'm 19 I like to spend my
free time at the gym I've recently got
into that wow that's so interesting
well you see this is what guys are
competing for so you can say anything
about yourself what makes you stand out
I like I go to the gym now
I bet that's that's it that's all I have
why am I so mean I'm joking of course
I'm sure they caught out all the things
that they said that was actually
interesting and just left the really
uninteresting parts all right so what
happens now Jesus Christ calm down dude
the hell it's not a fever oh so they
pick interesting what I'm not gonna get
one you see what I mean do you see what
I mean women like this shoot him he
needs to be shot not with real bullets
of course
Jubilees arey oh my god this is actually
a good idea Jubilee if you're watching
you should have liked paintball guns
just ready as soon as this cringe just
blast them that was so good oh my god he
look he looks just like for tonight's
treatment what's his name face Jarvis he
looks just like phase Jarvis this is her
first time dating three guys at once in
a white void between 1 and 13 6 7 what
was she hoping to get out of it all
right so I need to pick a partner what
can I ask them favorite number favorite
number
what would they say like a number she
doesn't like she's just got alright you
go you're right 13 who said 13 come here
September I'll forget the day I got a
wedding
I have family from like small-town
person we're like Myerstown have you
heard of that
yeah that's not part I'm actually a like
an independent filmmaker oh my God he's
identical to face Jarvis stand-up
comedians I've made you laugh about four
times so far oh yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm
counting how many times oh that's the
moment you realize like what you just
did on on YouTube it's [ __ ] cringe
well done to carry my emotional baggage
Jubilate please you need to do something
kill him kill it now obviously never
wish violence on anyone not okay but
kallab story or something that's like oh
hey I did this for me I once
accidentally during a cult it was an
accident it was an accident but I did
join yo what it was an accident
are we just gonna go past that come on
Jarvis you can do it I'm in between blue
and green is this how you guys pick your
partner's favorite color a favorite
number kind of grade school level is
this who said blue blue Uranus I'm all
about me I got injured and the resulted
oh my god this guy
it's literally me this guy's like this
join a cult can I just leave oh no no no
you just organically aligned okay we
just organically aligned
I feel for women when I see this this is
how guys interact with you gosh
now I understand I understand women then
I get it
awful yeah that's that smooth but tall
guy sure mood he set it up like a trap
do you like piano I'm a pianist boom
he's won it already this guy tries to up
him I play that what do you say what do
you play I play the cowboy I played a
cowboy Kelbo the [ __ ] use of cowbo
that's a dog you play a dog bro Kelbo
what's a cow ball am i stupid yes what
is cowbell what about the fourth guy
does he play an instrument the fourth
guy that didn't play an instrument he's
out he doesn't play an instrument
hey if you're if you're a guy in your
single the most effective thing ever
just pick an instrument literally any
instrument you can play the [ __ ]
cowboy that's all you need whether you
call it God or the universe
oh it's still just love in my connection
oh my god she actually doing her hair
and stuff god
I'm probably going to lemonade it's okay
guys guys handling rejection okay I mean
there's so many different options like I
don't know why I choose yeah because I
wanna [ __ ] like I could not give lesson
like what a hero God blessing God
blessing
oh it's all good it's all good
I swear guys fear rejection more than
anything in the world it's all good so
are you sort of a free-spirited so
nomadic oh my god he's so annoying
what's your favorite type of body of
water the ocean why what's your favorite
type of body of water this is this is
what you need to know I don't even know
what my chest favorite type of body
water is Oh God and I met I can't all
right I gotta ask her I cannot be
married to someone without knowing their
favorite type of body of water alright I
know favorite color
I know favorite number I don't know her
favorite type of body oh my god what's
the price we made it this far
alright what's your favorite type of
body of water question mark please reply
C question mark maybe lake all right
that's fine I'm more of an ocean guy
I thought you'd kind of cringe I don't
know I don't what's gonna happen from
here but she's you have waves they come
in come out gets affected by a lot of
things just making up a lot of stuff so
these guys don't have time to talk with
national you fare well please guys I'm
Chinese in Filipino so chew up you know
you know I think I guess Chinese man was
recorded okay alright nevermind a
nothing never working out it was kind of
hard so I mean yeah I was never fat oh
and so one day I just went with one of
my friends to the gym and I was just
like let's do this wow she's so
interesting so like one day I was like
not fit and just like I decided to go to
the gym and I was like I'm in the gym
now and then like I did the gym stuff
and I yeah this is what guys are
competing for this is the trophy I'm
beaming I'm sorry I'm sorry it's just a
joke oh my god take a deep breath
why is she pretending like she's not
just gonna pick the tall guy god I hope
she picks the guy in the left they
practically look the same just cover
their faces oh my god they are the same
please and they're equally annoying -
this is great power couple what dirty
play the cowboy did you not hear that
[Music]
badda-bing will you marry me no sobbing
yeah guess some guys can't handle
rejection respect respect hold on hold
on I didn't notice this I didn't notice
this okay that's the guy that you play
the instrument point proving I know it
pick up an instrument next time [ __ ]
in my home addict journey
oh my soup yeah I'm very susceptible to
peer pressure so whatever you say is
it's probably gonna work if one day
you need to sleep for the Chinese next
year I will be there ah all right I just
like flowing and listening to my
intuition on my calendar going whatever
I should pick me because I can cook
whatever you'd like for me to cook like
this guy doesn't play cello so what's
good about you this guy doesn't play the
cello it's so fine oh okay okay okay
okay please please pick then please pick
talk to you so much now you know you
I've talked to your nuts so I don't ever
want to talk to you again standing there
and like who's gonna pick you why are
they picking you it's probably just
based off of initial attraction like you
don't really know anything about each
other right away I mean just being next
to a pretty girl is like hot I like
making me smile now what if I made the
wrong choice I appreciate that
Wow Wow what the hell the sweet victory
of a man huh feels good doesn't it I
mean I'd be open to it um that's not a
yes by the way that's definitely not a
yes you picked him I'm looking for
somebody to work out with yeah I mean
honestly I just don't like working out
with just like other people so maybe
her only personality the only think we
know about her she doesn't want to do
within God bro I don't like working out
with other people too but maybe you
could just like alright fine we can work
out a couple times together
that's some way as a first date or
something god damn who almost messed up
that handshake that was almost trench
vote boji that's his name it's gone
phenomenal it's always an excellent day
my friend it was more so just some drugs
is this guy self watching to bring out
my experiences of similarities that I
see in her I just wanted her to know
about it it was just like yeah it's cool
though the tall guy said imma like this
full talked himself into elimination
the tall guy said nothing cuz he's tall
I'm tall toes that's why I'm angry so
stop all the hate on the long haired
dude I'm tired of liking them bruh
whatever drugs the long-haired guy was
on I don't want to do them hey thanks
for the like I realized it's not the
drugs this dude is just super these
comments have no chill I love it 56,000
Mike's back I was annoying and you all
know who I'm talking hey if you're
watching this annoying guy at least you
have long hair a link at least you have
that the long blonde haired guy and
Aryan would be the most annoying couple
that's kind of wanted them to hook up to
be honest that would be [ __ ] funny
they deserve each other
alright gamers hope you enjoyed this
episode subscribe if you want more
episodes check out to jewbilee subscribe
and smash like and all that stuff edgar
you want to say something
look edgar knows when I'm doing the
outro that's when he wakes that this dog
is so dumb but for some reason he can
tell like when I'm done with the video
so you're not so dumb are you look at
him yeah we're done we're gonna you feed
me now you okay and that's it for me for
now see you tomorrow gamers hey Dora
hey hey hey hey hey you know what big
peepees do they play PewDiePie's pixel
ings of course pixel ings
is a creature collecting game I'm the
primary shareholder over a bazillion
players have downloaded and it's got a
perfect score it's safe to say it's the
most popular game of all time 55 pixel
aims it's awesome deal with it deal with
it
[Music]